you're bad how are you great I'm Rachel
with Entertainment Tonight nice to see
you nice to see you happy birthday buddy
thank you very much yeah this is a
pretty amazing way to celebrate my
birthday I'm happy I'd say so so it's
tonight after it's tonight's after party
gonna turn into your official birthday
party I think you know all the costs are
here a lot of the crew are here this was
an incredibly difficult job to put
together so I think we're all going to
celebrate together celebrate the work
I'm not really a birthday person so it's
kind of you know interesting that this
has fallen on this night but I'm just
really happy to be here
happy birthday we hope you have been
able to celebrate well today one and
like you said today is quite a celebrity
you are serving double duty here you're
wearing multiple hats the first time
that you've executive produced a
television show you're also starring in
it so how was it juggling the two hats
on sets especially whenever the topics
are so heavy it was interesting you know
the the producing side of things was a
really steep learning curve yeah you
know
being on set performing in this role
going to those Dark Places while also
you know handling certain issues that
happen on every day on a film set was a
little bit overwhelming but I had an
amazing team of people Alexandra Akiva
Ali all of the people at Apple were so
supportive of me so so much so that
you're wanting to do it again oh I would
do it again for sure absolutely I loved
it being a part of the edit working with
the producers building the show casting
everything I loved it how much of
yourself started to blend with this
actual character Danny because like I
said some of the topics are super heavy
did you feel like the two were
intertwining and what did you do to just
like unwind and step away from character
on that it's interesting I don't think
emotionally I was blending with the
character but I just couldn't escape his
look because I had that crazy haircut
I'd come home from work I'd have the
circles under my eyes I'd see myself in
the mirror and Danny would be looking
right back at me so as soon as we wrap
the show as soon as we'd walked offset
for the first time Rachel took the
shears cut my hair right off and I was
good that haircut was something else man
yeah I don't think that's going to
become a trend after this please don't
one and done what is what hasn't been
one and done of course is Spider-Man
five years ago was your first one
homecoming
um fans cannot imagine anyone else
assuming the role how long do you think
you'll carry on the towards of
Spider-Man Betty I think as long as we
can do justice to Peter Parker as long
as we can keep elevating the IP and
making the films better and making them
mean more then I'll be there I'd be
stupid to say that I wouldn't be the
luckiest kid alive if I got to do it
again
there's stuff going on but we'll have to
just wait and see what happens we know
there's stuff going on yeah I heard a
lot going on yeah Amy Pascal loves a
headline she does she does